مهمه صعبه يواجهها فريق الدفاع عن ترامب
فهو يواجهه 37 تهمه كفيله بارساله للسجن
الا ان الرئيس الامريكي السابق اكد انه لن
يستسلم مرارا وتكرارا فما هي الخيارات
المتاحه امام ترامب المتمسكه بالبراءه
صحيفه نيويورك
لها المسارات التي قد يسلكها محام الرئيس
السابق امام القضاء فهم سيشيرون الى ان
ترامب رفع السريه عن الملفات التي بحوزته
قبل مغادره البيت الابيض وليس بعدها
وبالتالي سيقلبون الطاوله على الادعاء
ويتهمونه بسوء النيه وقد يظهرون ترامب
ضحيه لمحاكمه غير عادله التقليل قال ان
محامي ترامب سيبذلون قصار جهدهم في منع
وصول القضيه لهيئه المحلفين وقد يلجاون
للضغط على الحكومه بطلب الكشف عن هذه
الوثائق السريه وهو امر يصعب تحقيقه وفقا
لمحللين وفي حال لم تنجح اي من هذه
المحاولات التي ذكرتها الصحيفه سيحاولون
بلا شك المماطله في القضيه قدر الامكان
املين بان تتاخر لما بعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في المقابل وفي حال اصبحت ترامب
رئيسا مجددا قد يامر بنفسه المدعي العام
بغض النظر عن القضيه او يعفو عن نفسه بكل
بساطه